foreign
to Elizabeth in the NYC what's up
Elizabeth how we doing
I'm good Dr John how are you we are
rocking on how how's things in New York
oh boy it's crazy I mean it's cold one
day I mean we got Spring today we'll
probably have winter tomorrow fall the
next day it's crazy out here but hey
gotta love it this is New York right
we're crazy out here hey you you said it
not me I'll just let you I'll let you
have that one I'll let you know so
what's up
oh
oh Dr John
um
oh geez
I need help like
I just don't know where to start I mean
I'm a mess my life's a mess my marriage
is a mess but I'm struggling struggling
for a long time now with my marriage I
mean how do I deal with a husband that
just doesn't lead
usually when somebody I'm gonna make
some people mad when somebody usually
when somebody tells me
their husbands not leading oh boy
um that means that their husbands are
terrible mind readers or they're super
lazy they won't get a job they're just
they're just they're just bums so oh boy
tell me what what is what does the
phrase he's not a leader what does that
mean to you
um
so I guess underneath that is that he
just doesn't give his 100 percent
I mean it's it's what does that mean e
he well he doesn't like
bond with our son I am overwhelmed with
responsibilities that you know I need
help with and I've asked for this help
from him for years and like nothing
changes happen right here
um two things
um number one he's not giving a hundred
percent
is very different than he's not bonding
with his son
I mean but I I count that as not giving
your hundred percent no I'm telling you
he's failing his son
exactly it's that's that's not giving a
hundred percent you get I I tell I tell
my son I I get it yeah so here's what's
important for me
um
I can already tell you have to be very
careful with your language in your home
don't you
I do okay can't do that here we have to
be super honest with each other is that
fair
y yeah okay your husband is failing your
son
mm-hmm
right now number two you said you've
been telling him for years this is this
is you and me two new best friends
have you been very clear or have you
said things like I could just use some
help around here I sure am tired hoping
he would understand that means hey I
need help with bedtime need to re-roof
the house and then we need help
additions or have you said will you
please help with the dishes
oh my goodness
um it's been
Dr John it's been
it's been seen
16 years together and I I couldn't even
begin to imagine how many times we've
had this conversation
um it's uh straightforward you know uh
I've even had to switch uh you know uh
when we have these conversations like I
know it can't be you know after an
argument or when things are tense I've
tried to talk about it when we're calm
and things are good I've tried to uh
you're gonna hate my answer oh my God
you know what I'm saying I've tried
everything I've tried everything that's
not true
you don't think so I know so
how
you're still there
oh my god well it's true well I but but
we have been separated twice almost got
divorced like three years ago and I mean
I I really
I it's like I want to to I want to work
this I want to keep my family together
but he doesn't he doesn't Elizabeth
ah he doesn't want that he wants a maid
and he wants someone he wants someone to
take care of his kids so he doesn't have
to and he wants someone to sleep with
every every once in a while
yeah that that yeah that that's
ridiculous it's been months and months
and months like how can I and my my main
thing Elizabeth doesn't want it
hi hi he doesn't I mean behavior is a
language what's he telling you I don't
care what you need I don't care what's
gonna make you whole I don't care what's
gonna make you well I care about me
right
why are you but you're but you're
fighting it you're like going to the
ocean you're getting mad at the waves it
just is the only thing you can control
here you can't so your question to me
was how do I deal with a husband who
won't lead you can't you can only deal
with you
yeah
well you're you're staring at a purple
unicorn and you so badly want it to be
red and it's not
it's not
oh man but it's like ah but it like it's
and then it's too it's like it's been 14
years like what am I gonna do like like
be out there a divorced mom like
struggling with two kids like I I just
what message do you want your kids to
get
oh geez if this is what love looks like
or this is what self-respect looks like
you know what it's it's really it's
crazy because my best friend you know
kind of said something like that to me
and I thought about our daughter and
since the age of 10 this child has been
saying yo I'm never getting married I am
never having kids I don't want any of
that and I think back and I'm like how
at 10 years old does does she figure
this out already like she absorbs
everything is
right
is the air she sees your disdain she
sees all the stuff that I have on my
plate that's not it that's not it she
feels your resentment
she feels how much you disdain that man
when he walks in the room because you
can't stand it yeah but worse than that
you can't stand you Elizabeth
because in every facet of your life in
every facet of your life you are a
straight gangster
you're a girl yeah Mom you're a great
provider
you no matter what it is you get it done
yeah except for for some reason
you don't think you're worthy of being
loved
so you just keep taking it you just keep
taking it or or your fantasy about what
you want this thing to look like is is
has more weight
then somebody sitting down at the
kitchen table before you go to work and
saying two things
every day I thank God that I get to be
your husband and how can I love you
better today
oh my God I'm I'm sorry because it's
it's so true like I swear why why do you
think so little of my friend Elizabeth
because I like her it seems like since
the day I was born I'd just been in
survival mode Dr John like I've had to
fend for myself in so many different
areas of my life you know I my parents
split up you know and from the age of
seven I didn't have my father in my life
and I've just been out here just trying
to make it in life you understand and
listen listen to me listen to me kills
me because you think okay you're married
you have someone to do life with but I
find myself still surviving every damn
day and I'm just like how how do I deal
with this without without breaking up my
family that's the only thing that I
think about but you're not breaking up
your family you're right your husband
did it he has
your husband uh
I'm trying your parents were divorced
y'all are essentially divorced too
you don't sleep together you don't do
life together you don't share you don't
share expenses y'all don't do anything
together
no except you have this fantasy that I'm
keeping the family together
you're not
you're y'all are divorced you just live
in the same apartment in New York
it's it's true it's true that's how I
feel I feel like it is your mom most
times anyway it is
you just haven't you haven't you have
more laundry to do
yeah
now I never I want you to hear me very
carefully I'm using a technique on you
okay
here's the technique I'm using I am
hitting the pendulum really hard in One
Direction
and the reason I'm doing that is I want
you to push back hard and say no no no
this man loves me and I love him I am
not in a business of telling people to
get married unless very rare situations
I mean I mean I'm sorry I'm always
telling people to get married I think
marriage is awesome I'm not in the
business of breaking up marriages
telling somebody they should get
divorced right except in very rare
moments
so I'm leaning on you
and every time I ask a harder and harder
question you're like oh God you're right
oh God you're right that's true
I want to honor your your
sweet beautiful
nine-year-old kid that's still wondering
why Dad laughed
why what was so wrong with me I was a
beautiful little girl why'd you leave
exactly what I I did for so long you
know and yeah you still are
but he laughed your husband left I want
my son to think that there's something
wrong with him because his father
doesn't want to spend time with him get
to know him do things with him I I don't
want my my daughter to think that there
was something wrong with her like like
but you but you can't make that choice
your husband has to be a father and he's
choosing not to so he has taken that
cinder block and dropped it into their
tiny little backpacks and said hey y'all
carry this
I want to do something else
yeah yes how
how I can't help but change the way I
see him like this is not the man who I
thought I married but it's it but it is
the man you married
ah Dr John so listen choose guilt over
resentment
choose guilt over resentment
what uh what that mean
that means I can do one of two things
when my well and I'm just gonna make up
a story because she doesn't do this if
my my mom says Hey for Thanksgiving you
all are driving all the way to Texas
and I'd say hey we can't we can't afford
that drive it's too far for that short
of a time and she said and she she says
something like you will be at my house
we do Thanksgiving at my house you will
be here I don't care where you live
don't disrespect your mom that way I
when she if she were to do this and
again my mom would never do that if she
did I would have a choice
I could pile my family up in the car put
the trip on a credit card and be raged
out angry the entire trip
when my daughter says Daddy I gotta go
to the bathroom say come on come on just
hold it we gotta I can be that Dad all
the way there and all during
Thanksgiving I could be annoyed that I
was there checking my phone waiting to
see what what what work stuff I'm
missing
um then all of a sudden you know my mom
says hey go pick up some pizzas so I
gotta put more money on the credit card
right I'm just gonna end in Rage in
resentment and Ash
or I can say Mom I can't make it this
year
we are not coming I love you if you
choose to take this as a sign of
disrespect you're you're free to I think
the best way I can show you respect is
to honor my wife and my kids and my
family because you taught me to do that
and I'm going to do that in this season
and I'm gonna hang up the phone I'm
gonna feel so guilty
for bailing on my mom but I'm not gonna
drag me and my family through
the hell that is resentment
that feeling of just disdain when
somebody walks in right or if he looks
at you and says hey let me get the kids
to bed early tonight and you just want
to throw up like gross like I'm you know
you know what I mean
yeah
or he comes home drinking again or he
comes home not at all and then he shows
up the next day and wants to know where
breakfast like just just all of it all
of it right your kids are absorbing
every second of that and that
seven-year-old little girl still
wondering why he leave me too
he's sitting on my couch but he left me
too why
why so true
and so here's here's the hard place
where you find yourself
it's a place where I don't like to be I
don't know anybody who likes to be here
you have to choose reality
not the fantasy that you want to keep up
not the protection of that
seven-year-old little girl
she's been fighting your fights for a
long long time Elizabeth
if choose reality
for 14 years I've told my husband I need
some help
I need you to love me
enough to help out with these kids I
need you to take your son and connect
with this young boy who's looking to you
as the picture of what man who looks
like a father who looks like what love
looks like what compassion looks like
what responsibility looks like I need
you to connect with your daughter my dad
didn't do that to me and I'm still
haunted by it I need you to make sure
that girl knows that come hell or high
water
she's the most beautiful thing that ever
walked the Earth and there will be a man
that loves her
every moment for the rest of her life
and that's her day
and if he chooses not to do that you've
got to live in that reality and then
you've got to ask yourself that
terrifying question what am I going to
do next and I'm not saying you got to
get divorced am I saying that at all
but you've been separated separate
several times you almost got divorced
like you've been down this road before
but something keeps bringing you back
and it sounds like it's the fantasy it's
the picture of I also know that the data
is really clear when
um a woman chooses to leave
especially women with kids her net worth
goes down the chances of ending up in in
poverty are significant it's hard and
more frustrating his net worth often
goes up
super frustrating I get all that so I
know there's a lot of complications here
you've got to get some friends in your
corner that you can sit down and lay all
your stuff out and say here is reality
what am I going to do next
you've been fighting for a long long
long time let's set the gloves down and
let's exhale
let's get some water and let's meet with
our coaches and figure out what what's
the game plan because what we've been
doing isn't working
it sounds a lot like you got one option
left and I don't want to put that on you
but it sounds like you've done
everything you could you could put your
head on your pillow at night no one I
gave it my all
I gave it my all